the nba playoffs resumed today following
a three-day players-led boycott of games
the pause as they've called it came in
the wake of jacob blake's shooting
they are returning to the court after
agreeing with nba owners on a unified
action plan to fight racial injustice
which includes working to turn arenas
and possibly practice facilities into
voting locations for the upcoming
election
during that pause i spoke with nba
players association vice president andre
iguodala
who shared some of the players mindset
from the nba bubble in orlando
can you give us a sense of what it is
like for you with so much going on
outside that you want to be a part of
but knowing that you have a platform by
playing inside that bubble
yeah it's one of those circumstances
where it can be the perfect storm
uh for the mind to kind of you know tear
you down but i think what we've been
able to do is
knowing before we got here you know
we're coming here with a purpose
understanding it so we realized it was
the ultimate decision was to come down
here and play
for something bigger than ourselves and
bigger than basketball and
a lot of people don't want to talk about
the financial aspect of it but you know
building
building wealth for our communities uh
you know
us being able to accumulate that wealth
and then being able to take it back to
our communities
and at the same time bringing the
awareness which is the main goal coming
out here
shedding the light using this platform
you know you're seeing a lot of
reactions to what we've been doing from
other leagues and and that shows a lot
of power
or a lot of influence that we're having
and using the influence in the right way
just to shed light
on a lot of the social injustices that
have been occurring it's just the
beginning of time
i think doc rivers said that you love
this country but the country
isn't loving you back and i i had an
interesting uh
conversation with killer mike uh who's a
rapper and we've had many great
conversations before coming to the
bubble
things we should try to do to bring more
awareness to the situation and then try
to build up our communities
through our platform as well and he had
similar uh sentiments and saying you
know
it's interesting how we've been all over
the world but
you know at the end of the day we still
would rather live here
and that's the struggle in the mind
constantly
you know just looking for a place in the
world where we're accepted as equals
what did it come down to for all of you
to agree that you wanted to keep playing
i think ultimately it's it's you know we
wanted to
take a step back we wanted to regroup
refocus and just like a refresh button
because it's just
things can get heavy in your heart and
you know sometimes you ask yourself
what's your purpose
and what it boils down to is is the
platform working for us to
get our messages out there and there's a
real human issue here
and we're just trying to shed light on
that and we're going to try to
put things in place to change that so it
was really the platform
understanding how big our platform is
and when they've been telling us to shut
up
and and dribble because they don't want
to hear his talk so we realize if we
aren't playing
it's going to shut us up and we're not
going to be dribbling so you kind of get
hit
with the double whammy and we realize
you know we can we can have just as much
leverage doing both you know playing and
speaking and
being about change and the action is
there anything else that you would want
people to know about what's been going
on
there in orlando over the last couple
days that maybe we're misunderstanding
or not seeing
uh you know i think you look at the
athlete and it goes all the way back to
you know uh you know greek mythology and
we looked at these godlike beings but at
the end of the day we're humans
and you know we have feelings we have
emotions and although we get people
away from their issues and bring joy to
them we need time to
focus on our mental health as well and a
big part of that is
uh you know you want the next generation
to be better than you are
and and wouldn't be right if we left
those uh
communities that we grew up in we left
them behind when situations like this
happen
and that's why i wear group economics on
the back of my jerseys it's all about
building up my community and trying to
close that wealth gap
and again if you just look at it they
were so worried that their voices were
not being heard because they were there
people were focusing on the play
this was their moment to say hey pay
attention and now they're taking action
so you look at those action steps like
trying to help with voter registration
and combat some of these injustices
interesting to hear about what might
happen in some of these the arenas of
the stadium
both before the election and after right
and now that's their push yeah when they
stopped playing
they got our attention